ก็
สวัสดีค่ะพี่เอกสวัสดีค่ะน้องเรียมราคา
โอ้ยนักเรียน
อะไรลืมนักเรียน
บุหรี่ไม่เห็นครูเรียมไม่ได้ทำคลิปด้วย
กันหลายวันนะคะอะวันนี้วันอะไรนะคะครู
เรียมวันนี้วันนี้วันเสาร์สีม่วง
ใช้ห่า
สีม่วงก็ต้องวัน
วันเสาร์ใช่ไหมคะวันเสาร์ค่ะที่หาหาชาติ
ของกูออก
อยู่ที่นี่ค่ะ
คุยหาต่อไปอ้ออยู่ที่นี่ค่ะ
คู่เตรียมก็ติดใหม่เปิดก่อนนะคะอ่าหยิบสี
สีม่วงเอ่อหน้าประตูมทำให้ไม่เป็นสีม่วง
[เพลง]
วันเสาร์นะคะมันเสาร์วันที่เท่าไหร่นะคะ
ครูเรียมวันที่ 10
33 นะคะเดือนอะไรคะครูเรียมเดือน
พฤศจิกายนเดือนพฤศจิกายนนะคะปีพตเท่าไหร่
คะครูเรียม
ผช
2564 ค่ะปีคศเท่าไหร่คะคอสต์
2014  21 ค่ะคะคลิปนี้นะคะเป็นคลิปที่
6 เมตร
คิดว่านะคิดว่า
คิดว่าไรค่ะก็จะอาเป็นอาอาเบสวันเสาร์วัน
นี้วันเสาร์วันที่ 13 เดือนพฤศจิกายนพ.ศ
2506  14 พ.ศ
2046 อับครูเรียมเนี่ยไม่ได้เห็นกันหลาย
วัน
นานนานธรรมดาเนี่ยพรุ่งนี้ใช่ไหมคะพรุ่ง
นี้จะเป็นวันอาทิตย์
วันอาทิตย์เนี้ยวันอาทิตย์ครูเอ๋กับครู
เรียมจะเจอกันนะคะจะเจอกันใครค่ะจะเจอกัน
ในซูมสู่แปลว่านาทิตที่แล้วครูเรียมที่
ไหนก็ไม่เห็นครูเรียมครูเอ๋ก็เลยอ่ะครู
Arty กูอาทิตย์โอเคครูเรียมไม่อยู่ครู
อาร์ตี้มานะคะๆ
หัวหน้าคู่เตรียมไปไหนมา
คู่เรียมไป
เดินป่าเดินเดินป่าเดินที่ไหนอ่ะคุณเรียม
จะแชร์สกีหรือผู้เก๋แช่ kuasa ให้เนาะอ่ะ
ชาย
คุยว่าง
คุยเก็บเก็บสีก่อนนะคะทุเรียนเดี๋ยวมันอก
แล้วก็
อ้าวแล้วกูเอาปากกาไปไว้ที่ไหนก็เจอแล้ว
ปากกาว่าที่คอมพิวเตอร์
นี่เป็นปังงานะคะแต่เป็นปากกาวาดที่
คอมพิวเตอร์คู่เตรียมไปเดินป่าเดินบนภู
เขาไหมคะ
ใช้ค่ะก็มีภูเขาเนาะ
แบบนี้เนาะที่ครูเรียมไปเป็นแบบนี้อ่ะ
ก็
มีภูเขา
ถ้าป่าเนี่ยมีภูเขามีอะไรอีกคะมีต้นไม้
ต้นไม้
มีต้นไม้
ต้นไม้เดี๋ยวคุยว่าต้นต้องต้นไม้มากๆด้วย
ใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะป่าต้นไม้มากๆ
มีต้นไม้
แล้วต้นไม้ต้องมีสีใช่มั้ยมีหญ้าไหมคะมี
ค่ะมีหญ้ามีหญ้า
[เพลง]
มีก้อนหิน
เอก้อนเขียนสีน้ำตาลน็อคก้อนกิงใช้ค่ะ
ก้อนหิน
ให้ไปสีด้วยอ่ะ
มี
การเขียนสีน้ำตาล
อุ้ยฮ่าๆๆขอโทษนักเรียนจะบอกทุกครั้งเลย
คุย
แต่ก็ต้นไม้ก็ปิดอ้าวเห็นไหม
เครื่องหมายสีน้ำตาลใช่มั้ยต้นไม้ทำจาน
ไปแล้ว
เฮ้ยขอโทษค่ะทำไมเป็นแบบนี้
ไม้สีน้ำตาลใบไม้สีเขียวได้ไหมสีเขียวให้
ค่ะ
ว้าวว้าวๆๆ
[เพลง]
ฮะโอเคได้ป่าวล่ะ r-cooh คูเรียมไปเดิน
เดินป่าเดินปัญหางั้นก็อันนี้คงเก็บไว้
กูเรียนนะกูเรียมอยู่ที่นี่เก็บ
เดินเดินป่าที่เดินเดินทาง
แบบนี้หรือว่าเดินขึ้นภูเขาค่ะเดินขึ้นภู
เขาค่ะมาเดินขึ้นภูเขานะคะแล้วโคเรียมไป
กี่คน
ไป
9 คน
9 คนนะคะ 9  9
คน
ไปทั้งหมด
9 คน 9 คนผู้ชายมีกี่คนคะ
นักเรียนชายกี่คนนั้นเมื่อกี้เตรียมทำมือ
1  2  3  4  5  1  2  2  3  3  4  4  5
5  6 ผู้ชาย 6 คนผู้ชาย 6 คน
งั้นผู้หญิงก็สามคน
ใช่ค่ะผู้หญิง 3 คน
รวมกันชนะบวกกันรวมกันเท่ากับ 9 คนโห
งั้นเดินป่าเดินขึ้นภูเขาสูงไหมคะ
สูงค่ะสูงคู่เรียนรู้มั้ยประมาณกี่เมตร
กี่กิโลเมตรสูง
มี
อายุเดินเตรียมเดิน
8 กิโลกรัม
ขึ้นไปขึ้นถนน
8 กิโลเมตรใช่เดิน 8 กิโลเมตรใช้เวลา
AE ชั่วโมง
ใช้เวลา
ประมาณเจ็บ
7 ชั่วโมง
เดินขึ้นภูเขา
ใช้เวลา 7 ชั่วโมง
ใครเมตรเนี่ย 8 กิโลเมตรถ้าเดินใน
ช้อปปิ้งมอลล์เนี่ย
1 ชั่วโมงได้ไหม
ได้ 1 ชั่วโมงชนะเสร็จแล้วแต่อันนี้เดิน
ขึ้นภูเขา
ครบ 7 ชั่วโมงเฮ้ย
เฮ้ยค่ะเพราะว่าภูเขาสูงมากๆสูงคู่เรียม
แล้วพระอาทิตย์น่ะ
พระอาทิตย์ร้อนไหมอ่ะเวลาโคเรียมเดิน
มองไม่ร้อนค่ะไม่ร้อนไม่ร้อนเพราะมีต้น
ไม้ต้นไม้ขอเยอะมากๆมีต้นไม้มากๆก็เลย
เดินสบายๆสบายไม่สบายเหนื่อยไหมคะเหนื่อย
เหนื่อย
เรียมหายใจเฮ้อเฮ้อ
เหนื่อยเพราะๆห่อเหนื่อย
มีน้ำไม่มีน้ำไหมนี่ค่ะมีน้ำแล้วครูเรียน
เวลาเดิมเสือป่าเนี่ย
ข้างบนบนภูเขาว่ามีโรงแรม
หรือรีสอร์ทไหมคะ
ไม่มีค่ะอ้าวเดินขึ้น 7 ชั่วโมงแล้วเดิน
ลงนะคะว่าไอ้ค่ะเตรียมไปกลางเต็นท์ขอ
นอนข้างบนใช่ไหมข้างบนถูกเขาใครเขา a ลืม
กูเรียมเวลาเดินจากข้างล่างเนี่ยข้างล่าง
ขึ้นเวลากี่โมง
หงอ
เตรียมเดินขึ้นเวลา
8:00 น
แล้วถึงข้างบนข้างบนเนี่ยนักเรียนตรงยอด
เขาชนะยอดหมอเขากี่โมงคะ 8  9  10  11  12
1  2  3 บ่าย 3 บ่าย3โมงใช่ค่ะ 03:00 น
03:00 น
15:00 นถึงยอดเขา
โอ้ย 7 ชั่วโมง
ข้างบนไม่มีโรงแรมไม่มีค่ะอ้าวแล้วกิน
อาหาร
ยังไง
ข้างบนมีร้านอาหารอ๋อแถวนี้มีมีร้านอาหาร
พรุ่งนี้ไหมมีค่ะอ๋อมีร้านอาหารที่นี่
ไม่มีโรงแรมไม่มีรีสอร์ท
แต่มีมีร้านอาหาร
ดีมีที่นี่ Love
มีโต๊ะเก้าอี้
ตู้
มีมี
ลาย
เดียวแล้วดื่มน้ำ
มี
ร้านขายน้ำนะคะมีอาหาร
โอเคนึกว่าไม่มีอาหารไม่มีอาหารเหนื่อยนะ
คะอ่ะเหนื่อยมากเอ็กคูลเรียมครูเรียนบอก
ว่าไม่มีที่นอนนอนเดี๋ยวนะคะคุณลบตรงนี้
ก่อน
นอนทุก
นอนเต็นท์ใช่ไหมคะค่ะเป็นนี่คือแบบนี้ใช่
ไหม
ใช่ค่ะ
นอนเต็นท์
มกินยาไม่หาย
ไปเดินเดินแล้วเหนื่อยใช่มั้ย
ใช่ค่ะ
เหนื่อยนะคะอ่ะอ่ะดื่มน้ำไหวมั้ยโอเคโอเค
ค่ะไหวไหมอ่ะโอเคค่ะงั้นครูเรียมก็
ต้องการเป็นแล้วก็นอน
นอนที่เต็นท์นะคะให้หานอนในเต็นท์แล้ว
เต็นท์เต็นท์ของครูเรียมหรือเต็นท์ที่ภู
เขา
เป็นของเรียม
แบบ
โอ๊ยกูถ้างั้นทุเรียนไม่ต้องมีที่นี่กู
เองว่าคุณเอ็มไหม
ตอนขึ้นเรียมแบบนิดเดียว
อ๋อแล้วก็ที่นี่มีมิตรเป้ใช่ไหมใช่ค่ะมี
เป้เป็นที่นี่นะคะ
ตอนขึ้นค่ะเตรียมไม่ได้แบกเต็นท์ of
เพื่อนผู้ชายผู้ชาย
เตรียมจ่ายเงิน
ไม่ใช่เพื่อนแต่ว่าให้เพื่อนมีคนไทยใช่
ไหมคนไทยที่นี่
คนไทยเราพูดว่าลูกหาบ
ลูกหาบก็ให้เงินลูกหาบแล้วลูกขาดก็แบบ
เป็น
กี่บาทโทรหาหมู 1 กิโลกรัม
30 บาท 1 กิโลกรัม 1 กิโลเมตร 1
กิโลกรัมหรือ 1 กิโลเมตร 1 กิโลกรัม
กับ 8 กิโลกี่บาท
หนัก 1 กิโลกรัมใช้ค่ะ 1 กิโลกรัม
30 บาทขอคนนี้ก็จะมี
มิดเป็นมีโค้กเป๊ปซี่
ไข่แล้วก็แบบก็เดินๆ
ถ้าถ้าที่นี่ 10 กิโลกรัมกอล์ฟ *  30
=  300 บาทอ่อนร้อยบาท
[เพลง]
แปลกคนไหมแบบค่ะตัวเอสคุณครูเอกคนเดินไม่
โอเคๆอ๋อก็ 1 กิโลกรัม 30 บาทนะคะครู
เรียมน่ะเดิน 7 ชั่วโมง
ใช้ค่ะ 7 ชั่วโมงลูกหาบเนี่ยเดินกี่
ชั่วโมง
เตรียมไม่รู้
ฟ้าลูกค่ะแต่ว่าออกไปไปไปรอรอ
มีคนมาโอเคโอเคใช่ไหมของครูเรียม 5
กิโลกรัมของคนนั้น 3 กิโลกรัมคนนี้ 5
กิโลกรัมลูกหาบแบกได้
30 กิโลกรัม 40 กิโลกรัมใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะ
แล้วก็คู่เตรียมไป 50
แปะ 4 กิโลเมตรลูกค่ะโอเค start เด้ออ่ะ
ไม่
ใช่
ลูกขับเดินขึ้นเดินลงอ่ะเดือนขึ้นอาจจะ
2-3 ชั่วโมงชนะ 2 ชั่วโมง 3 ชั่วโมงเรา
ก็เดินลง 2 ชั่วโมง 3 ชั่วโมงแต่ครูเรียม
7 ฉ7ช่วงค่ะแต่ว่าตอนเดินขึ้นเด็กช้าช้า
เดินช้าค่ะตอนเดินลง
โรงเร็ว
เพราะเวลาเดินขึ้นดูดูดูวิวใช่ไหมคะ
เหนื่อย
ลงไม่เหนื่อยหรอคะโหลดเหนื่อยนิดเดียวอ๋อ
ยังเด็กๆนะครูเอ๋นะขึ้นก็เหนื่อยลดลงก็
เหนื่อย
มาฮ่าๆๆแล้วครูเรียมข้างบนหนาวร้อน
ข้างบนหนาว
กี่องศาเซลเซียส
ประมาณ
17 องศาเซลเซียลตอนกลางคืนนะคะตอนกลาง
คืนหนาวนะหนาว
หนาว
แล้วทุเรียนเวลาเดินเดินขึ้นเนี่ยเวลาเอ๋
ฟังเดินป่าใช่มะป่าปากขึ้นมีต้นไม้
ต้นไม้น่ะต้นไม้
ค่ะอ่าหาย
ป่าที่ป่าเนี่ย
มีมีตัวนี้ไหมคะอ่ะจะ
เปลี่ยนไหมเนี่ย
เหมือนไหมน้อไม่เหมือนเดี๋ยวนะต้อง
เจ้าหญิงลูกเอกกำลังวาดรูปอะไรภาพใช่ไหม
คะให้ถ้าว่าอา
สีแดงๆเนาะอาร์
นักเรียนมันจะดีดี
มันจะคลานใช่ไหม
ค่ะอ้าว
ตรงนี้นักเรียนเส้นเลือดมันจะ
กิน
นักเรียนเส้นเลือด
เส้นเลือดถ้า
ชาติหน้าจะเกาะ
เวลาถ้าออกมาตัว
แต่เวลาเกาะแล้วก็
ดูดเรื่องใช้มันจะดูดเลือดเข้าไปถ้าเจาะ
อ้วนเลยอ่ะครูเลียมมีทากไหมคะมีฮ่าฮ่าๆ
มีถ้าอยากให้ดูลูกคุยนี่กูเองกูอยู่ว่า
ไม่เหมือนใช่ไหมที่จะกลัวไหมอ่ะ
โอเคไม่เป็นไรให้เป็นดู
เผย
ถึงไหม
โอ๊ยใกล้ๆหน่อย
โอ๊ย
ถ้าเป็นนักเรียนตอนเนี้ยถ้า
ทากแล้วก็เกาะที่ขานะคะที่ขาใช่ค่ะ
เกาะขาเกาะมือก็ได้นะคะเกาะคือ
อาเบเกาะขาแล้วก็ดูดจุดเรื่องนักเรียนให้
มีอะไรคะมีค่ะมีธาตุนี้ครูเรียมกลัวมั้ย
กลัวค่ะกลัวแม่ข้า
มาเกาะที่หลังเท้าเดียว
เกาะจริงๆหรอคะใช่ค่ะโอเคค่ะคู่เรียมว่า
ได้แล้วนี้เก
เป็นยังไงคะ
ถ้าเหตุพาด
อันนี้เป็นขาขาของเรียมเป็นเท้านิ้วเท้า
ขอดูท้าว
คุณมี 4 นิ้วเท้าหรอคะฮ่าๆๆๆๆๆๆๆ
นิ้วให้เราพูดเลียมคู๋วัดเท้าให้ใช่ไหม
โอเคค่ะแล้วเขาเรียนพระธาตุเขาเช
โอเค
อันนี้ขานะคะขากุเรียม
ทุเรียนใส่กางเกงขายาวใส่กางเกงขายาวค่ะ
โอเคไปกางเกงแล้วก็มีเท้ามีนิ้วโป้งนิ้ว
ชี้นิ้วกลางนิ้วนางแล้วก็นิ้วก้อยเขาโอเค
นี่เป็นเท้าโอเค
S2 เท้าเนาะ
อุ้ยกางเกงไม่เท่ากันขอโทษค่ะ
1 นิ้วโป้งนิ้วชี้นิ้วกลางนิ้วนางนิ้ว
ก้อยใส่รองเท้าไหมคะใส่ค่ะเตรียมน้ำเป็น
รองเท้าอะไรอ่ะเป็นรองเท้ารัดเริ่มต้น
บังคับ
ไม่ใช่ค่ะ
แต่ตอนนี้
ค่ะ
แบบนี้ค่ะกูเอกกำลังตกใจ
ใช่แล้วทีนี้กูเที่ยวกูผิดตกใจอยู่
คุณเรียนไปขึ้นภูเขา
ใส่รองเท้าอันนี้ล่ะคะ
ใช่ค่ะ
เฮ้ยเดินขึ้นพวกเขามาต้องใส่รองเท้าแบบ
นี้
เรียงเอาไปคู่เดียว 1 คู่
หน้ารองเท้าอะไรนะนักเรียนมันเป็นรองเท้า
มันเป็นรองเท้าเดินป่า5สๆรับ
รองเท้าสำหรับเดินผู้เขาอ่ะเกรียมอันนี้
ต้องไปผ่าไปภูเก็ตนะคะเลี้ยงมไม่ใช่นัก
นี้เดินได้ค่ะอยากได้เขาว่าแล้วทำไม 7
ชั่วโมง
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
แล้วอันนี้เดิน
ภูเก็ตเดิน
ฮาวายเดินเป่า this  OK เดินเดินขึ้นภู
เขามีต้นไม้
ไม้
ใช้รองเท้าอันนี้
เท้า
เดินเหนื่อยมาก
เสา
เรียงคิดว่าเลี้ยงคิดว่าถ้าเกิดโดนน้ำอ๋อ
คนน้ำ
ฮะโอเคขอเผื่อฝนตกเหรอคะพี่เรียมใช่ค่ะ
ฝนตกเชื่อ
[เพลง]
ผู้เรียนต้องมีรองเท้า 2 คู่ค่ะโอ้ a คะ
มันหนัก
หนัก
ลงเท้าอันเนี้ยใส่แล้วก็เดินเราก็รองเท้า
อันนี้สำหรับข้างบน
เรียนเอาไป 1 คู่ 1 คู่
เข้าใจ
และต้องไปด้วยไปให้ค่ะลายแล้วก็สูงค่ะ
แล้วเกิดอะไรขึ้นคะรองเท้าแบบนี้มีถ้าขาด
ตัวเองค่าก็
ไปก่อนนะก็เห็นลบ.มทีเดียวกัน
โอเคคุณเอ็มเศียรค่ะ
มีภาพมาเกาะเกาะกรงไหนหลังเท้าหลังเท้า
อ้วน
ไม่อ้วนอ่ะค่ะ
มักเกาะเกาะหลังเท้าก็
ตัวมันรู้สึกไหมมันก็เล่น
ตามนี้ใช่ไหมคะ
ไทยหา
อ้าย
ก่อนนะเล็กๆนะคะก็จะมานี้อันนี้มือหลัง
มือทาเท้า
เกาะหลังเท้าคะเกาะแล้วไม่รู้ฉันไม่รู้
ถ้าอยู่ที่นี่น่าจะกิน
เลือกแล้วถ้าก็จะใหญ่ผู้ใหญ่แต่ครูเรียน
น่ะขอถ้าเกาะเรียน
ใช่รู้
รู้ค่ะรู้เย็นตอนนั้นเตรียมถือกล้องถ่าย
รูป
อยู่ในเมืองค่ะต้องถ่ายรูปพอเตรียมรู้สึก
รู้สึกถ้ากรอบเท้า
1 รอบ
เดี๋ยวครูเรียมก้มฤดูไหมดูเรียงดูเห็น
แล้วก็ไม่ดู
ร้องเสียงดังใช่ร้องอะไร
เล่นสวัสดีค่ะ
เรียบร้อย
แล้วก็กล้องเหรอคะขายวีดีโออยู่ค่ะแต่ว่า
กล้องขยับ
ไม่ยนต์กล้องนะไม่ตากล้องขยับถ้าเป็นครู
เอ๋นะอันนี้กำลังถ่ายรูปอยู่ถ้า
กล้องไปแล้ว
กูเลี้ยงก็กล้องยังอยู่ซะเลยคะไก่ค่ะค่ะ
เพื่อนของเรียมเพื่อนที่มาด้วยกันค่ะ
เลื่อนออก
อันนี้เรียมค่ะ
เพื่อน
เพื่อนเพื่อนดีดทากออกจากหลังเท้าเพื่อน
มีมือแล้วก็ดีดอ๋อ
[เพลง]
ไม่กลัวธาตุไม่กลัวเพื่อนไม่กลัวแต่คน
ทั่วสันต์เวลา
ง้อตัน
ขอโทษนะคะครู a หัวเราะมากๆเอา
จริงๆกูเอ๋น่ากลัวมาก
ถ้ากูเอ๋ไปคิดไปถูกเขาคู๋จะมีมีอันนี้นะ
คะอันนี้กูเห็นลบของคุณเรียมได้ไหมอ่าน
ได้อ้ะ
ตัวเองมีอุ้ยไม่ใช่
คู่เอกจะมีอันนี้เลยถูกมีรองเท้า
รองเท้าแล้วผู้เอกก็จะมีเป็นรองเท้า
พลาสติก
ง่วง
เป็นคล้ายๆถุงพลาสติกแล้วก็มีตรงเนี้ย
ผู้
แล้วก็มีกางเกง
กางเกงติดที่นี่อีกที
นะหนู
มีแล้วคู่เอกก็มีมีอันนี้ด้วยคนเดียวตัว
เองก็จะมี
มีขวด
ขวดอะไรคะสเปรย์
จะเปห้ามฆ่ามาคุยจากสเปนไม่กลับหัวผิว
สเปรย์เยอะๆ
โหเพื่อนเพื่อนๆก็ไกลๆเพื่อนเหม็น
เพราะว่าคู๋กลัวถ้า
แต่ครูเรียมใส่รองเท้าอันนี้ถ้าเกาะ
ให้ค่ะ
Love ตกจะเรียนเตรียมใส่ใส่ถุงเท้านะคะ
ใส่ถุงเท้าอ๋อมีมีถุงเท้า
ใช่ธเมื่อเช้า
ฆ่าข้างบางกอกฟิล์มถอดถุงเท้าออก
ขอถุงเท้า 5
ข้างในหรือเกาะที่ถุงเท้า
คือตอนเช้าตอนเช้าเล่มตื่นขึ้นมาไม่ใส่
ถุงเท้า
Scholl เวลาเดินขึ้นใส่ถุงเท้าใช่เวลา
นอนชนะนอนมีเต็นท์
เต็นท์
คูเรียมนอนที่นี่ตื่นไม่มีถุงเท้า
ถุงให้มีหัวผ่าไม่อ่ะตัวเองอ่ะ
ถุงเท้าไม่มีไม่มีถุงเท้า
แต่ว่ามีเต็มไปเดิน OK
[เพลง]
และก็เลยภาคมากตอบที่หลังข้าวใช่ค่ะ
น่ากลั๊ว
น่ากลัวมากทุกเกรียมแล้วสวยไหมคะที่ภูเขา
สวยค่ะสวยมากๆสวยมากๆต้นไม้เหมือนมากต้น
ไม้ตีอ่ะหรือว่าสูงต้นไม้สูงสูงมากๆ
คูเรียร์มีรูปให้นักเรียนดูไหมเดี๋ยวคู๋
ปั๊ปใส่ปีนของกูเองนะให้มีค่ะคู่เตรียม
แชร์รูปให้นักเรียนดู
อันนี้คือเป็นอ่าเต้นของครูเรียมนะคะเป็น
ของเรียมสีชมพู
ค่ะ
เป็นสีชมพูอ่ะ
ถ้ากูเรียนนอนคนเดียว
นอนกับเพื่อนมีเพื่อนนะคะนอนกับเพื่อนใช่
ค่ะ
แล้วก็มีย่างเราจะมีปัญญากูมืดแชมพูหน้า
มืด
ใช้ผู้เลี้ยงอาบน้ำที่ไหน
อาบน้ำนี่ห้องน้ำข้างนอกนะ
มีห้องน้ำหรือเปล่าคิดว่าไม่อาบน้ำอาบท่า
ฮ่าๆๆนะค่ะแล้วไม่
มีมิตรต้นไม้ไหมมีค่ะครูเอ๋อยากเห็นต้น
ไม้
[เพลง]
เพราะว่าครู them เดินขึ้นภูเขามีป่าก็
ต้องมีต้นไม้นะคะมีต้นไม้
โอ๊ยโอ๊ยกูต้นไม้ค่ะต้นไม้สูงๆสูง
เดี๋ยวเพื่อนอะนี้เพื่อนเรียนเหรอคะมี
แป้งแล้วก็มีอะไรคะถือไว้มีไม้
ไม้เดินภูเขา
อันนี้ลูกหาบใช่ไหมลูกหาไปรูปเข็น
ครึ่งขึ้นไปบนภูเขาแล้วจะเป็นทางราบอา
สวัสดีขึ้นข้างบนแล้วก็ราบต้นนี้นักเรียน
คะเราเรียกว่าต้นสนเนาะต้นสนต้นสน
วิมีรูปอีกไหมคะมีค่า
เขาวันนี้นะคะอ่ะคนไทยเรียกผู้เขาชื่อ
อะไรที่คนไทยเรียกว่าอะไรนะผู้ภูกระดึง
ค่ะครูกระดึงภูกระดึง
สวยนะสวยมากนะครูเอ๋ไม่เคยเดินขึ้น
คิดภูกระดึงภูกระดึงภูกระดึง
นี่หัดเดินป่าออกไปแต่ก็มีค่ะมีราวนะคะมี
ดาวที่ใจจะเป็นแบบนี้นะคะจะ
เวลาเหนื่อยใช่ไหมกูแต่นี้เดินสบายขึ้น
น้อ
ไม่ค่ะไม่สบาย
สบายก่อนไม่มี
เมื่อก่อนไม่มีเราเราไม่มีนะ
ก็เป็น 8 ตอนนี้เป็นไผ่เนาะแล้วก็เป็นป่า
เป็นย่า
ไปค่ะ
นี่ลำธารด้วยนะคะจะไม่มาดูลำธาร
ไม่ใช่แม่น้ำและนักเรียนมันเล็กๆเล็กๆพูด
ว่าลำธารโอก็มีต้นไม้มีก้อนหิน
มีน้ำนมมีก้อนไข่น้ำต้องถิ่นมีตะไคร่แล้ว
ก็ไม่ใช่ป่ะมีมอส
ตะไคร่น้ำให้ตรงนี้แล้วก็มอสมอสแล้วก็มี
น้ำว่ายน้ำไม่ได้คะ
ได้ค่ะจะให้ว่ายน้ำได้นานอาบน้ำที่ลำธาร
ได้ไหม
อาบน้ำที่ลำธารเรียงคิดว่าได้โอเคค่ะแต่
เรียมอาบน้ำในห้องน้ำผู้หญิงผู้หญิงผู้
ชายโอเค
ผู้หญิงไม่ได้แต่น้ำที่ลำธารดื่มได้ไหม
ดื่มได้นะคะก็ได้ใช่ป่ะเผื่อได้คนคนที่ภู
เขาก็ดื่มนะอ้าแต่คนกรุงเทพฯบางทีไม่ดื่ม
เนื้อแดงถ้าไม่มีน้ำคะโอเคคิ้วน้ำ
ฮ่าๆๆไม่มีถ้าใครอ่ะ
มีลำธารด้วยอ่ะมีอะไรอีกคะคุณเดียวมีน้ำ
ตกด้วยนะคะมีทั้งตก
ใช่
โอ้ยอยากไปละ
ชอบน้ำตก
สวยมีก้อนหินก้อนหินเยอะมากโอ้โหน้ำตก
เล็กๆเนาะใช่หะน้ำตกเล็กๆแล้วก็จบงานใหญ่
ๆก็มีค่ะมีใหญ่ๆด้วย
[เพลง]
คุยไม่เคยไปจริงๆค่ะ
ไม่รู้ว่าภูกระดึงดีน้ำตกมีน้ำ
หน้า
ที่อะไรอ่ะสีดำคนน่ะคนค่ะ
มีแม่มีลำธารมีน้ำตกมีต้นไม้ก้อนหิน
มีอะไรสวย
โอ้ยอย่าลืมให้ดู
มีดีอะไร
อุ้ย
คนสวย
เพื่อนเรียนใช่มั้ย 1  2  3  4  5  6 ห้า
ผู้ชาย 1  2  3  4  5  6 ผู้หญิง 1  2  3
ทำไมที่นี่มี 4 คน 4 คนเป็นพี่สาวพี่สาว
ของเพื่อนอ๋ออ๋อออฟน้ำหนัก 9 คนชายแล้วก็
มีพี่สาวพี่สาวอีกสองคน
ทั้งหมด 11 คน
ใช่ไหมแต่ว่าเพื่อนๆคนนะ
สิบคนฆ่า
ทำไมอ่ะกูเรียนบอกเมื่อกี้บอกว่า 9 คนแต่
ในรูปนี้มี 1  2
3  4  4  5  6  7  8  9  10
คูณเรียมที่ไหน
ริมอยู่ข้างหน้า
อ่ะ
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
คู่เอกคิดครูเรียมถ่ายรูปขอ
ครูเอ๋จำครูเรียมไม่ได้
10 คนใครถ่ายรูปติด
ตั้งกล้องไหมค่ะอ๋อ
อันกล้องฟิล์มก็วิ่ง
[เพลง]
กรูอีกเอ้ยเห็นแล้วรองเท้าโอ้ทุกคนหนึ่ง
ของ 3  4 คนใส่รองเท้าสำหรับเดินทะเลค่ะ
ฮ่าๆ
[เพลง]
เขาเหรอคะสบายๆค่ะพี่เอ๋สบายๆภาคก็เลยมา
ใช่
หน้าโอเคก็ถูกกระดูกก็กี่เมตรเมื่อกี้กู
เห็น
เมื่อกี้
1,000
288 เมตรนะคะถู
สูงนะคะสุดๆๆ
มี
อะไรหายร้อยประมาณ 5.5 ถ้าเดินขึ้นเลยไม่
เบรคนะไม่เบรคไม่แวะอ้าวก็
500 บาท 5,500 เมตร
ชาย /  500 ก็ 5 กิโลเมตรครึ่งตรงเลยนะคะ
ชายค่ะใช้เวลา
3 ถึง 5 ชั่วโมง
3 ชัยประทุเรียม 7 ชั่วโมงเพราะว่าไปทาง
นี้ไปทางนี่
ก็เป็น 8 กิโลเมตร
55.5 กิโลคือเดินขึ้นเดินขึ้นไปแล้วก็มี
ทางราบอีสานกิโลเมตรเขาหมายถึงตรงเนี่ย 5
กิโลกรัม
ใช่ทางขึ้น
โอ๊ยโอ๊ยโอเคบ๊ายบาย
ครูเอ๋ไปแล้ว
เห็นเหนื่อย
ถ้ามีเฮลิคอปเตอร์ลงโอเค
มีรถขึ้นโอเคนะคะอ่านภูกระดึงสำหรับเด็กๆ
โอเคเนาะคู๋ 53 เดินขึ้นไม่ได้ล่ะโอเคหัว
เขา
เรียนคะหัวเข่าไม่ใช่นี่อ่ะ
หัวเข่าเนี่ยคู๋
ขวดเขาเนี่ย
ไม่ค่อยดีอ่าพักขึ้นลงคิดว่าไป
โรงพยาบาลก็
ต้องไปโรงพยาบาล
โอ๊ยไม่เป็นไรกูเอ๋ดูรูปโอเคทุเรียนไป
เที่ยวสรุปใช่มั้ยคะเรียงสนุกสนุกค่ะ
เตรียมไป 3 วัน 5 นอน 3 วันอาหารอร่อยไหม
อร่อยค่ะอาหารอร่อยมากๆ
อยากไปว่าอาหารได้แล้วแต่ทุเรียนตอนเนี้ย
หมดเวลา
เลยเวลาแล้วหมดเวลา
อ่อยเลยแล้วต้องไปแล้วค่ะกูเองหิวข้าว
โอเคค่ะเดี๋ยวไว้เจอครูเอ๋กับเตรียมใหม่
คลิปหน้านะคะนักเรียนภาษาเก็บนายคลิปนี้
ไปก่อนเจอกันพรุ่งนี้นะวันอาทิตย์
ใช่อาทิตย์เจอกันบ๊ายบายค่ะบ๊ายบาย
ก็สวัสดีค่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนนักเรียนเอ้ออ้ะ